[Music]
on this Saturday night bursting the
balloon America takes action
a U.S fighter jet takes out China's
balloon but what was it looking for the
investigation begins China is not a
country to be trifled with
cold alerts keep coming when milder
weather is final
to 95 percent uh recoverable material
electric cars creating a new kind of
waste the Canadian company taking charge
and coming up with Solutions
I want to have my own spot with like
this whole it's going to be like a dog
Disneyland type thing a bus ride and a
and of our kids the staff of dreams for
dog
owners
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us we begin with developing news
out of the U.S and a critical moment in
U.S China relations this afternoon the
U.S military shot down a suspected
Chinese surveillance balloon as it made
its way off the coast of South Carolina
just shot it dude
they shot it
recovery of the balloon is now underway
and an investigation will soon begin
into its Mission Washington says it was
sent to monitor strategic sites in the
continental United States and is a clear
violation of U.S sovereignty China is
still insisting the object was a weather
balloon blown off course the giant
balloon about the size of three school
buses had been floating across the U.S
for the past few days after making its
way over Canada
Canada's minister of National Defense
says Ottawa unequivocally supports
America's actions and that the
government has been closely engaged with
its U.S counterparts the order to shoot
down the balloon given by the president
marks a tangible escalation in tensions
between the U.S and China and it comes
just days before what was supposed to be
a diplomatic meeting between the two
superpowers so the question now what
happens next Jennifer Johnson reports
after the suspected Chinese surveillance
balloon spent days Crossing parts of
Canada and the United States the U.S
military took action shooting it down
moments after it moved past the North
Carolina coast
the best time to do that was we got over
water outside it was in our women's 12
mile limit the Department of Defense
says it had already weakened the balloon
surveillance capabilities earlier this
week it's believed to have traveled near
sensitive military sites across North
America including U.S InterContinental
missile silos in Montana we have to send
a very clear signal to China that this
is unacceptable China claims it was a
meteorological balloon that drifted off
course and it never intended to violate
another country's airspace but now a
second suspected Chinese balloon has
been spotted over Latin America experts
say it was launched the same week the
U.S announced new military bases in the
Philippines 160 kilometers from Taiwan I
can only imagine what the reaction would
be in China if they were on the other
end Lincoln canceled this weekend's trip
to China as tensions escalate but
Beijing claims no formal visit was ever
announced President Biden was advised by
military leaders not to shoot down the
the balloon while it was overpopulated
areas fearing falling debris could harm
citizens but some Republicans disagreed
with waiting we're talking about
defending our Sovereign airspace and I
don't think the Chinese Communist Party
would hesitate to shoot down an American
asset that was in their airspace the
Pentagon says there's no evidence the
balloon was carrying any nuclear or
radioactive materials but exactly what
information was collected and what
technology was on board won't be known
until the debris is recovered President
Biden is spending the rest of the
weekend at Camp David and will be
speaking with top military leaders to
get some answers Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington
the balloon is also raising concerns
over our national security and the
future of U.S Canada relations with
China especially ahead of U.S President
Joe Biden's visit to our country next
month on this week's edition of the West
block our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson sat down with U.S ambassador
to Canada David Cohen to discuss the
threats China poses here's just some of
what he had to say
I know that you are briefed on
intelligence and security you're a close
friend to the president Canadians are
looking at this and they're concerned
and so are Americans what can you tell
us about the incident in terms of the
significance that the Chinese are
actually flying a balloon over North
America with intelligence gathering
capabilities so
um I think it's a reminder of the need
for us to be vigilant the need for us to
fund an adequate defense the need for us
to have at an adequate technological
defense I think it's a reminder of the
importance of NORAD to Continental
defense for both Canada and the United
States on the other hand let's not jump
out of our shoes here I mean this is a
balloon that was at very high altitude
my information is that there was never
any no American citizens or buildings
were ever in Jeopardy for this the
balloons were well above commercial
airliner flight patterns and this is
this is not the first time that this
type of a device has been floated over
the United States it has happened
previously so then
to be more about China sending a message
we can do it if we want to then what
it's actually gathering in terms of
intelligence so I hate to I hate to
speculate what China's motivations will
be and you notice their public comment
of course is that this is so it's
Gathering weather data and it drifted
off course I'm I'm not sure I believe
that it's Gathering weather data but
it's entirely possible that it drifted
off course and that it was no never any
intention to have it flying over you
know over this part of this part of the
United States so I said but I don't want
to speculate about what China is up to I
am I'm happy
to comment though that this really
should be a reinforcement for all of us
for our public that
China is not something China is not a
country to be trifled with they are a
legitimate threat to the United States
and Canada from a military perspective
from a defense perspective from an
intelligence perspective and from a
trade perspective and I think it
underscores the reasons for sound and
consistent policies by both Canada and
the United States toward China
you can catch Mercedes full interview
with the U.S ambassador to Canada
tomorrow right here on global extreme
cold blizzards and snow all words
synonymous with the Canadian winter but
conditions this past week and weekend
have been severe with many parts of the
country remaining under public weather
alerts on Friday parts of the country
saw temperatures dip to minus 35 and
although some regions are experiencing
more seasonable temperatures today
warnings from Environment Canada are in
place across the maritimes Ontario and
Quebec Mike troulette reports on how
Canadians are coping in this cold
when you can see the cold air in the
harbor it's a good idea to stay inside
unless it's a visual too dramatic to
pass up with the wind it's probably in
the -30s it's a great day to be out and
if you have the clothing it's you know a
great day to be out and see the scenery
see the harbor on a really cold day they
call it sea smoke when the Arctic air
mixes directly above the warmer Harbor
water a similar scene played out in St
John New Brunswick where a wind chill
dipping into the minus 40s let the
streets eerily calm but the frigid
temperatures crept indoors for some with
many in the maritimes experiencing the
brunt of the polar vortex in the dark
more than 30 thousand customers were
without power at one point in the region
today we're making the investments in
Nova Scotia the extreme cold came days
after the utility review board approved
a 14 hike to electrical bills despite
the province urging the independent body
to reconsider I'm surprised that they
found their nose at Nova Scotia is the
way they did to be honest in back where
80 percent of homes are heated by
electricity the provincial utility is
pleading with homeowners to conserve
energy after setting usage records the
last two days
the cold snap was so extreme the start
of Quebec City's Carnival was delayed
until Saturday afternoon
winterlude in Ottawa was similarly
affected but oddly enough even with the
cold the Rideau Canal has still yet to
open the latest delays seen since the
national capital commission started
clearing the ice in 1971.
polar vortex reached well into the U.S
as well with New Hampshire's Mount
Washington the highest peak in the
northeastern U.S setting temperature
records with wind chills touching
-77 Celsius
but at least the system is nearing its
End Toronto was miserable with cold on
Friday
disgusting I don't like it but Saturday
saw a gradual thaw and a return to a
normal winter
microl Lake Global News Toronto dozens
of Russian and Ukrainian prisoners of
War have returned home following a
prisoner swap
a top Ukrainian presidential aide says
116 ukrainians were freed including
troops who held out in mayuple while the
city was reduced to ruins Russian
defense officials say 63 of its troops
have returned following the swath
including some whose release was secured
after mediation by the United Arab
Emirates
a state of catastrophe remains in place
in Chile after an intense Wildfire
continues to spread throughout the
country's Southern and Central regions
the fires fueled by a heat wave that saw
temperatures hit 38 degrees Celsius are
responsible for the deaths of at least
13 people some of whom died while trying
to escape the Flames although hundreds
of fires have been contained the
forecast for the coming days remains
risky that's according to updates
provided by the government
the family of obesity police officer who
died by Suicide four years ago says a
Coroner's inquest decision this week has
brought them a sense of justice
Constable Nicole Chan took her life
after filing complaints about two senior
officers having inappropriate
relationships with her now a jury has
made 12 recommendations for the BC
government and Vancouver Police to
prevent another tragedy from happening
meet the garchow reports and we want to
warn you first that the story contains
some disturbing details
she would be very happy that she's
finally listened to Jen Chan reacting
with a sense of relief after a BC
Coroner's inquest into her sister's
death by Suicide made 12 recommendations
following seven days of testimony things
that need to be changed and we're very
satisfied in the fact that you know
other people also think so and hopefully
it will be you know put into action
Constable Nicole Chan took her own life
in January of 2019 after she made formal
complaints about sexual assault and
extortion against a supervisor and a
night after she was apprehended under
the mental health act she had been a
member of The Vancouver Police
Department for nearly a decade we heard
that in her last moments at the hospital
that she really just felt like nobody
was listening to her the jury heard Chan
struggled with severe depression and
PTSD after alleged inappropriate
relationships with Human Resources
officer Sergeant Dave Van Patten and
supervisor Sergeant Greg McCullough
among the twelve recommendations aimed
at preventing a similar tragedy
mandatory rigorous and regular in-person
respectful workplace training for all
officers annual psychological check-ins
and mandatory psychological interviews
as part of the recruitment process the
whole point of the inquest was to show
that Nicole never wanted to be a Victor
him she found herself in that way and
how can we help her stop being a victim
Chan was released from hospital an hour
and 20 minutes after being triaged hours
later she was found hanged from her
bedroom door the jury's recommendation
for Vancouver General Hospital the
treating doctor should have direct
communication with First Responders and
family members and for the Ministry of
Health to maintain a database of
patients with suicidal ideation he
ultimately provided us with answers to
expose the many shortcomings of the
various institutions that Nicole came in
contact with
Vancouver Police say Chan's death
highlights the importance of
conversations about mental health and
accountability in policing her family
remains hopeful for positive change
within the force and the systems meant
to support its members Nito Garcia
Global News Vancouver
if you or someone that you know needs
help you can call talk suicide Canada at
1-833-456-4566 supports available 24
hours a day every day of the year a
generational divide coming up why
there's a gap in education levels
between new and third generation black
Canadians
data from the latest census is giving us
a picture of Education levels among
ethnic groups across the country overall
racialized groups in Canada tend to be
highly educated among black Canadians
about a third have a bachelor's degree
or higher which is the same as Canada's
population as a whole but the
differences are quite Stark when you
look at black Canadians who have
recently immigrated to Canada and those
who have lived here for Generations Kyle
Benning explains some fish are spiny a
number of factors go into succeeding at
school family can play a big part of
that Chris Thompson's parents moved to
Canada from the Caribbean he says he
wouldn't have attended the University of
Toronto if it wasn't for the people
around him I was fortunate to be
connected and met mentors that pushed me
further than just uh sports for Canada's
black population family background can
determine the likelihood of success at a
post-secondary institution that
according to 2021 Census Data recently
released my statistics Canada about a
third of Canada's black population will
receive a bachelor's degree which is in
line with Canada's population as a whole
but within that group there are clear
differences when you break things down
what you see is that the black
population includes some very highly
educated groups as well as some with
much lower levels of Education the
report puts the black population into
three groups African immigrants and
their children Caribbean immigrants and
their children and black families who
have lived in the country for for
several Generations the data shows more
than 40 percent of African immigrants
and their children leave University with
at least a bachelor's degree about 20
percent of Caribbean immigrants Reach
This Milestone while just short of 30
percent of their children receive a
bachelor's degree but for families who
lived in Canada a little longer only 15
percent achieve a bachelor's degree more
than half don't have any post-secondary
credentials
York University Professor Carl James has
written a handful of books looking into
education and Heritage he says the drive
from immigrant families for their
children to succeed is drilled into them
with the children recognizing the
sacrifice made by their parents when is
that moment the magical
James adds while familial support is
vital encouragement or lack of it from
teachers can play a major factor for
racialized kids who go through Canada's
K-12 system and sometimes if you have
these ideas about the students you're
teaching that will influence how you
think and how you work with the students
you know seeing people of the same
Heritage succeed at higher levels of
Academia and in careers also makes a
difference it's something Thompson and
the Federation of black Canadians are
looking to change by offering the
mentorship he received to students today
you're hearing it but the reality of it
is when you're going out into the
community you're not seeing that you're
not exposed to those people so it might
stunt the message from the reality of
where they drifted Kyle Benning Global
News
I had the scrap yards of the future how
electric cars are creating a whole new
recycling industry
[Music]
with gas prices remaining High Canadians
are looking for ways to cut their
emissions and electric vehicles are
becoming the preferred choice for many
sales of electric vehicles skyrocketed
last year increasing by 75 percent
worldwide but Innovation brings with it
new questions like what happens to the
car's massive battery pack when it dies
Krista Hesse sought out to find the
answer to that question this week for
the new reality and discovered a
Canadian company on a mission to make
sure those batteries don't go to waste
batteries power the technology that we
rely upon every day our phones laptops
and increasingly our cars
inside each electric vehicle are large
batteries containing Precious Minerals
such as lithium Cobalt and nickel when
EV batteries run out of juice some are
sent here to life cycles Kingston
facility where they are broken down and
recycled
life cycle is part of a new industry
that is emerging to meet the growing
demand for electric vehicles and the
minerals that are needed for their
batteries
so there's a big worry you know how are
we going to supply all the lithium the
Nicola Cobalt to make all these
batteries here the battery packs are
submerged in a water-based chemical
solution and then shredded the black
mass that is produced contains all the
valuable minerals that Lithium-ion
batteries need it's then shipped off to
be processed into raw materials that can
be used to make new batteries
so we're getting up to 95 percent uh
recoverable material from those
batteries last year electric vehicle
batteries made up 40 to 50 percent of
all the batteries life cycle processed
that number is expected to increase come
2030. when hundreds of thousands of EVS
are expected to reach their end of life
the hope is recycling can help to offset
the amount of mining that's needed to
create these batteries in the first
place helping to power a clean energy
future
pharah
Krista thank you for that and you can
watch the full story tonight on the new
reality coming up at 7 pm
next K-9 commute why this Calgary School
Bus has gone to the dogs
all right
[Music]
if you have a dog who loves car rides
and just can't wait to frolic at the dog
park then an Alberta family has created
a unique business just for you an
entrepreneurial mom and her son in
Calgary bought a bus not for people
though for taking pet pooches to and
from the park now it's a simple concept
but the results are absolutely adorable
Jill cruto went along for the ride
when this school bus hits the suburbs
it's not pulling up to pick up kids
coming to the doors of parents to take
their fur babies for a ride
it's about as adorable as you'd expect
oh it is a dream job yeah I can't really
get much better than hanging out with
dogs all day I grew up with dogs so I've
always loved dogs I trained dogs on the
side and I mean dogs
people in my books Denzel Morrison and
his mom who runs a rescue transformed a
bus into a Doggy Daycare equipping it
with harnesses to keep the dog safely
leashed in small Gates between the seats
keep them contained and if there's any
misbehaving who treats lots of treats
treats is the key once they're all
picked up the passengers settle in for
their final destination and they can
hardly wait
it'd probably be like someone's secret
life of pet stuff where they're just
like
they're like holy crap just get me off
this bus actually I just want to go to
the park
they're released into a private gated
Park where they can run wild
oh I know their owners are sure
satisfied with the service and exhausted
puff brings some peace to the home
having a new puppy and two young kids I
was looking for creative ways to have a
little bit of help and as I was
searching around the neighborhood I I
just came across it online and and it
I mean honestly it seemed kind of fake
at first it's so hilarious
Morrison hopes to build on the business
and expand to all of Calgary's quadrants
I want to have my own spot with like
this whole it's gonna be like a dog
Disneyland type thing and um that'll
have maybe one or two buses and I can
just like bring dogs all from all over
the city to my own area and like have it
like just really awesome I think his
Canaan customers would really like that
and as he said treats are the key that's
global national for this Saturday night
I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of our
whole crew here on global national I
want to thank you so much for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your Canada here it is it's snowy Little
River Reservoir in St John New Brunswick
we love seeing your Canada so please
email us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until we're together tomorrow take care
of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]